Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
we could all use
some holiday cheer.
Hi, Sharks.
Hi, Sharks.          Hi, Sharks.
Who's ready to ski
into a big old pile of money?
I've always
dreamed of that.
[ Laughs ]
Let's make a deal and put an end
to poo‐crastination.
Ba‐bam!
It's been a really crazy
Journey, but here I am.
That's the Christmas spirit
I like.
Adam: Let's make a deal.
I do believe
this is a game changer,
but I don't want you
to shop it around.
Oh, Barbara!
Bah, humbug.
And I'm sitting out here
like an elf in the cold.
[ Christmasy version
of "Shark Tank" theme plays ]
Narrator:
First into the Tank is a way
to make a big statement
during the holidays.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
Hi, Sharks.          Hi, Sharks.
I'm Amberly.
I'm Jennifer.
And I'm Kristy.
We're three cousins
from Houston
presenting
our Texas‐sized ornament.
We're seeking $150,000
in exchange
for 10% of our business.
Do you have more Christmas cheer
than storage space?
Are you tired of spending hours
decking your halls
and your yard?
Do you love
big holiday cheer
but hate seeing
all the melted snowmen,
the slayed Santas,
and the roadkill Rudolphs
flattened and deflated over
lawns the next morning?
Together:
Well, we have the perfect
holiday solution for you.
Amberly: Introducing...
Holiball!
Holiball!             Holiball!
The inflatable ornament.
It's inflatable, deflatable,
and reusable.
The all‐weather material
is UV‐resistant.
You can easily hang them,
stake them, sit them,
and even float them.
And they're
storage‐friendly.
You can fit three Holiballs
in just a shoe box.
This is the only time you'll
want to have big Holiballs
but a tiny package.
And we have the perfect
product just for you.
You have some samples here,
so let's try them out and...
Have a ball!
Have a ball!        have a ball!
So, I'm gonna take off my top
to show you how it deflates.
What I mean by that
is the top of my ornament.
Y'all dirty.
So, you pop the top,
[ Air hissing ]
pull the plug.
Takes about 30 seconds
for it to fully deflate.
Jennifer: And then to inflate
your Holiball,
you can use
any household air compressor.
We recommend
our Fast Flow Inflator,
which will inflate
your Holiball
in less than 30 seconds.
[ Whirring ]
[ Whirring stops ]
So, you'll easily
insert the nozzle.
Oop!
And then put your pin in,
and then your topper.
Oops. My hands are shaky.
‐That's it?
‐And voilà!
Happy Holiball.
So, which one of you Holiballs
thought this thing up?
[ Laughter ]
Amberly:
I have lots of crazy ideas,
but last summer, we knew
we wanted to do something
creative together.
I shared this idea
of the inflatable ornament,
and it sparked their interest,
as well.
We do all kinds of crazy parties
in our family.
We're always decorating.
We go over the top.
We've always wanted
the big commercial decor
you see in malls
and shopping centers,
but they cost
thousands of dollars,
they weigh
hundreds of pounds,
and there's nowhere
to store them.
And so we started researching
to see if we could find
anything similar,
and we could not find anything.
In July last year,
we searched and sampled
and sourced
all types of materials,
and we finally found
this material
that not only achieved
the aesthetic that we wanted,
but also the durability.
So, in less than
120 days,
we were able to produce,
package,
and design our ornament,
ready to sell.
Wow.
Let's talk sales.
Since starting November 1st
of last year,
we're at $171,000
in sales.
Good for you!
What do you think
you'll do this year?
So, we're projecting
$650,000 in sales.
Whoa!
Cuban: And what leads you
to project that, Jennifer?
And we will profit $300,000.
How do you base
that projection?
So, last year,
the only thing
that capped our sales
was lack of inventory.
We hustled the Christmas
markets last year.
We had no money
for marketing.
In three days, we sold $30,000
worth of Holiballs.
Yeah! Good job.
We completely sold out
of two colors.
In January,
we did $115,000 in sales.
So after Christmas,
you did $115,000.
Yes.
Give me
a very basic number.
What does this cost to make,
and what do you sell it for?
Amberly: Sure. So, they come
in two sizes ‐‐
18‐inch diameter
and 30‐inch diameter.
Is this the large
or the small one?
‐That's the small.
‐That costs $10 to make.
And you sell it for what?
Retail $40 and $60.
‐Whoa.
‐Wow.
What percentage of
your business is wholesale?
Sure. So, this year, 70%
of our business was wholesale.
However, COVID really
put a damper in our plans,
so we had to really
do a digital pivot.
[ Clicks tongue ]
Yes.
So we worked on our website,
our SEO optimization.
What's your biggest
obstacle?
So, our biggest obstacle
really is inventory.
We want to scale inventory
to get prices down.
And in order to do that,
we would need your help.
We want to move into
branding and licensing,
but also to help us
streamline the production
and really
distribution process.
For me, it's the seasonality.
that's so tough
having gone
into this space
three times now
over the last 10 years.
But look, guys,
I love it.
I think you guys
are very credible,
but it's just not a journey
I want to take.
And I would have to slam
such a royalty on this
that the ball would deflate.
[ Laughter ]
Amberly:
Mr. Wonderful, are you sure
I'm sorry ‐‐ I'm out.
you don't want balls
in your portfolio?
I do. I have balls.
[ Laughter ]
‐Thank you.
The valuation is pretty high.
It's $1.5 million.
Why do you feel
it's worth that much?
So, we're basing that on our
current and projected sales.
Amberly:
The thing is, there's nothing
like it on the market,
and we feel like we've proven
that people want it
in the fact that we sold out
the first three days
that we had it
on the retail market.
But you're also at the mercy of
how other people
run their businesses ‐‐
retailers putting it out
on the shelves
at the right time.
You know, you have a patent,
but somebody
will find ways around that,
unfortunately, right?
You're right.
It will be knocked off.
That's another reason
that we need you guys,
is to hit the ground running
before it gets knocked off.
Looking at product,
it's so visual and so much fun,
but I think you're way
out of line with your valuation.
You're projecting $650,000
in sales next year,
and I'm sure that influenced
the way you priced your stock,
but you have to remember that
that's what you hope to do.
I believe you'll do it,
but it's not proven.
I'm gonna make you an offer
based on where I think it is.
So I'm gonna
give you $150,000,
but I want 25%
so that I could be a full
Holiball right with you.
Thank you for that offer.
But I don't want you
to shop it around.
I'm not sure Lori has an offer,
but I'd like to beat her out.
[ Laughs ]
So you have to answer me,
but you can't entertain
another offer, please.
Whoa!
Oh, Barbara!
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Amberly, Kristy, and Jennifer
have an offer on the table
from Barbara
for their giant inflatable
Christmas ornaments, Holiball,
but she won't wait for them
to hear other offers.
Corcoran:
So you have to answer me,
but you can't entertain
another offer, please.
You waited all that time to come
here, and you're not gonna ‐‐
she's not gonna let you
listen to anybody else.
Because I know I'm giving you
an equitable offer.
I know I can help you.
What is great about this product
that you're not utilizing now,
I suspect,
is it's built perfectly
for social media
and promotion.
It's so visual.
Let me tell you
what I think.
Everybody up here
has digital access.
That is, if Barbara
will let me tell you.
So, Barb ‐‐
It's certainly up to you.
I don't mean to
force an offer.
I just think
I'm the dream partner.
It's a fair deal.
O'Leary: That's the Christmas
spirit I like.
It's a perfect offer.
John: Come on, Barbara.
I wouldn't push it
if I didn't believe it.
Bah, humbug.
Barbara, we would love to
partner with you,
but we'd also like to hear
our other opportunities
with the other sharks.
That's what
I'm talking about.
Okay. Then you don't want
this offer?
So, I'm the only one
who ever licensed any
Christmas products here.
A guy came on here
with a company called
Hanukkah Tree Topper,
and I licensed that out
to Kurt Adler,
the largest company
in the space.
So my offer is,
I'll give you ‐‐
Okay, I'm out.
Daymond,
how do you sleep at night?
How do you
sleep at night?!
Yeah, how do you
sleep at night?
He doesn't sleep at night.
You destroyed that deal.
Vampires don't sleep.
[ Laughs ]
I'll give you $150,000
for 20%,
and I will take 5% less than
what I was gonna initially offer
because Barbara's
such a mean person.
[ Laughs ]
I'll tell you what
I was gonna say.
You're gonna
let me speak ‐‐
I think it's only fair.
This is their moment, their one
moment on the carpet, right?
Wait a second ‐‐
do I hit that Mark Cuban
could be interested
in Holiballs?
Let me just tell you this ‐‐
I always wanted to
meet the women who had
the world by the balls, right?
So we'll do 25%...
$150,000 for 25%,
we're both your partners.
And you get both of us.
Whoa, Holiballs!
And you're $150,000
for 20%?
$150,000, 20%,
and I got
the licenses ready.
[ Whispering ]
I'm wondering if I got to
get back into this deal.
No, you don't want
to get back in the deal.
I know! I'm wondering
if I should go in with Daymond.
No, don't go in!
Daymond, should I
go in with you?
Come on in.
Hey, ladies. Daymond and I
just went in together.
Oh, no!
So, you two in $150,000
for 20%?
For 20. Yep.
And then you two are in
for 25%.
And I'm sitting out here
like an elf in the cold.
Sure you don't want back in,
Mr. Wonderful?
[ Laughter ]
[ Whispering ]
♪♪
Okay.
Barbara and Mark,
you have a deal.
[ Cheering ]
Boo!
Thank you so much
for your offers.
‐Horrible decision!
‐Thank you.
Why did you pick
Mark and Barbara
over Daymond and Lori?
For less?
There was no reason.
It was our gut feeling.
Good. Your gut is right on.
We're gonna make a lot of money.
Thanks, guys.
‐Bye.
‐Congrats, guys.
Oh, my God,
we got a deal!
Barbara was on board
from the beginning.
Yeah, she believed in us
right at first,
and that meant a lot, as well,
that she was willing
to put her neck
out there for the Holiballs
and she wanted
to be a Holigirl.
What more could you ask for?
Yeah.
So, we got a Holigirl
and a Holiboy.
[ Laughter ]
Daymond,
they threw you under a bus.
This is what you look like now.
That's right, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Narrator:
In season 7, Evan Lutz made
a deal with Robert Herjavec
for his produce‐delivery service
with a mission, Hungry Harvest.
For every bag we deliver
to one of our customers,
we donate a healthy meal
to someone in need.
Narrator:
Let's see what he's up to now.
Food insecurity means
you don't know
where your next meal
is coming from
or you don't have access to
healthy fruits and vegetables.
Over 35 million households
are food‐insecure.
At the same time, over
20 billion pounds of produce
go to waste every single year
in the United States.
In the five years
since "Shark Tank,"
Hungry Harvest has delivered
over 2 million boxes
to hundreds of thousands
of households
across the United States.
Most of our customers subscribe
because they love the mission.
We've now done
$50 million in sales.
Lutz:
25 million pounds of produce
that would have
otherwise gone to waste
are now in the hands
of consumers.
Love that.
Herjavec: The reason
I invested in Hungry Harvest
was the social mission.
We're helping people
that need a helping hand,
and if there's anything
that we've seen during COVID,
there's a lot of people
who need help.
I would never
in my wildest dreams
think I would be
making decisions
that had people's lives
at stake.
Lutz:
Fighting food insecurity has
always been part of our mission,
and now, with COVID‐19,
it's never been more important,
and that's why we launched
the Emergency Box Program.
So far, we've been able
to serve 65,000 boxes of produce
to help needy families
during this crisis.
I think sometimes
you just need hope.
You just need somebody else
to tell you it's gonna be okay,
and I kind of feel like
the country is
in the same place right now.
Herjavec:
This is a great business.
Not only does it help
the community, saves food waste,
but it's making a profit.
It is great to do good,
make money,
and do more good.
Lutz: Ever since I was a kid,
I've dreamed of becoming
a social entrepreneur
that helped people
and gave back to the community.
The last five years have been
nothing short of incredible.
Every single day,
I have to pinch myself
that I am living in reality,
that I'm really doing this,
that Hungry Harvest
has helped a lot of people
and become wildly successful,
and I could not be more grateful
for the platform
that "Shark Tank" has provided.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a perfect gift
for those who like to linger.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Katie Stephey.
And I ‐‐
[ Sighs ]
I'm sorry.
My husband
was supposed to be here by now.
A while ago, he waltzed into
the bathroom, phone in hand,
and I haven't seen him since.
He's what I call
a poo‐crastinator.
In other words, someone
who wastes time in the bathroom.
Adam, are you still
in the bathroom?
Adam: I'm just doing
the paperwork! Almost done!
Okay,
it's been 40 minutes.
[ Toilet flushes ]
[ Laughs ]
40 minutes?!
[ Chuckles ]
That would explain
why I can't feel my legs.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, Sharks.
Sorry I'm late.
My name is Adam Stephey.
And I'm Katie Stephey.
And we are
from Normal, Illinois.
We are seeking $200,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company, Katamco.
And now introducing
our most successful
product line to date ‐‐
The Toilet Timer!
‐Oh, no!
‐[ Laughs ]
Oh, hell no.
Ohhhh.
The Toilet Timer
is the perfect way
to tell someone to poop
or get off the pot.
Adam:
This is a sand timer
with a unique mechanism
that I invented.
It gives you about five minutes
to do your business
so you don't miss
anything important ‐‐
like pitching on
"Shark Tank."
Remember, Sharks,
the Toilet Timer
will take him
from infinite scroll...
To the toilet paper roll!
[ Laughter ]
Let's make a deal and put an end
to poo‐crastination.
[ Laughter ]
Cuban: Oh, my goodness.
You can't be serious.
[ Laughter ]
That's right ‐‐
I can't be serious.
It's very rare.
Let me just stand up
for all men in America
and say that is our only time
where we get privacy.
Let me just tell you
a fact of toiletry.
Katie: Yes.
If your legs
don't fall asleep,
you're not doing it right.
[ Laughter ]
Well, it can be a product
that guys don't want
but that a woman looks at
and says, "He needs this."
It's just supposed to be
a gag gift, though, right?
Greiner: It is a gag.
It's primarily a gag gift,
but there's
a practical side to this.
And what would that be?
What's the practical side?
That being on
the toilet too long
can be bad for your gut
and your butt health.
I think this would be a great
time to cue up Dr. Rieders.
Hi, Sharks.
As a gastroenterologist,
I tell my patients
not to stay on the toilet
for more than
three to five minutes.
This will prevent fissures
and hemorrhoidal bleeding.
The Toilet Timer
is certainly entertaining,
but it's a medical fact
that lingering in the loo
is bad for your health.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you, Sharks,
and good luck, Adam.
Corcoran: Oh, my gosh.
[ Laughs ]
I'm trying
to be pragmatic about it,
and I give everybody
an equal opportunity.
Ooh.
However,
I'm a little skeptical here.
Uh‐huh.
$200,000 for 10%.
We don't even know
what it sells for yet, Kevin.
We don't know
what it costs them to make.
Well, I'm excited
because a $2 million valuation
means there's
a lot of poo‐poo going on here.
Mm‐hmm.
We're totally
gonna get the numbers.
There's some great numbers.
Get us excited.
Christmas 2019,
quarter million dollars
in sales.
$250,000.
And what does it cost you
to make this?
Just under $3 landed.
And you sell it for what?
$14.99.
You've got to be kidding.
I know.
People are crazy.
But where did you sell it?
It's primarily Amazon.
What I want to tell you
about the product
is it lends itself
to licensing very easily.
So if you'd like to remove
your black hankies,
be our guest.
[ Laughs ]
Oh! Oh.
Kevin, how do you like
your new look?
I know I'm getting
a royalty.
[ Laughter ]
Kevin, I've seen your face
on a potato,
so I didn't think
this was a big stretch.
Yeah, listen,
I used to pooh‐pooh
these kind of tchotchke ideas
until I got into Potato Parcel.
Now I'm not laughing anymore
'cause I get
a big check every month.
Let's stay focused
on the numbers,
because you're
asking for $200,000.
How much is this going to sell
this year, in your estimation?
Okay.
You said quarter of a million
last year.
Yeah. It was $294,000
last year altogether.
That's huge.
Quarter million
since December.
How do we know
it's gonna sell again?
Well, how are you
promoting it, right?
Or are people
just finding it on Amazon?
What has happened
over the past two Christmases
is Amazon's algorithms
have picked up
that people like this
and they buy it,
so last Christmas, I didn't
spend a dime on advertising.
Good for you.
I have never ‐‐
Thanks, Mark.
What are you on track
to do this year?
If I walk out of here
with no deal today,
then I'll do
a million dollars this year
because that's all the product
I can afford to buy.
You'll do $1 million
in this crap this year?
Adam: Yeah, yeah.
Why would it go
from $250,000 one year
to a million the next year
without publicity?
That's such
a great question.
Because this year, we've already
done $318,000 of this SKU.
John: $318,000?
Katie: Yes.
And a quarter million of that
was this Father's Day, so ‐‐
How is this possible?
What planet are we on?!
We're on Planet Poop, man.
If I can walk away
with a deal today,
I believe that I can do
$3 million in sales this year.
I thought you said
$1 million earlier.
That's right. My bank
is not scaling with me.
He can do $1 million this year
with or without us, he's saying.
That's right,
and then $3 million
if I can get some help
getting inventory.
As we've looked at the
humps that have happened
over the past seasons,
we've got
a big Christmas on our way,
and I want to be
ready for it.
I have never been ready
for a holiday season,
and I've sold out
each season.
'Cause you don't have enough
inventory. That's the problem?
You need the $200,000 to build
more inventory?
Well, no, I need $200,000
for some other stuff,
and I need some more money
for inventory.
What other stuff?
John: What other stuff?
Well,
what I'd like to do is,
with $70,000
of the investment,
I can put that towards turning
our production line in China
into a higher‐volume
production facility.
But you have
great margins already.
Why would it be a priority for
you to even invest that money?
That doesn't make sense
to my ears.
It doesn't seem to me
like there would be
anything that you should
have to pay for
or supply to a factory,
if you don't own the factory,
that you would put
any money into whatsoever.
The factory should improve
their systems free
and ramp up
to accommodate you
and make inventory.
Absolutely.
You see why I'm here?
Is to learn from you guys.
Katie: Yes, exactly.
Well, don't fall down
that rabbit hole.
Do not give any factory
any money.
Just give them
more purchase orders
and tell them
that they should figure out
how to ramp up the speed
of the making of the product.
That's good advice.
I think you guys are great.
I think a lot of people
will buy it,
but it's just not
the kind of thing
where I feel like I could
come in and give you anything
that's really super beneficial
to blow up your business.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
Adam, I respect sales,
and you have them.
The trouble with this deal,
though,
is you're asking
for $200,000.
Alright? This is a gag company.
I get it.
But $200,000's too much.
Okay.
Way too much for this.
I'm out.
Okay. Thanks, Kevin.
You're thinking
this is a business.
It ain't.
It's a gimmick, alright?
And you can make
a certain amount of sales,
and it's gonna burn out.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
How much did you start
the company, this product with?
Well, my whole company
was $300.
And you're gonna do
a million dollars this year?
Yeah. For sure.
At least.
I think that's
extremely impressive, right?
Yeah.
But on the other side,
I have a personal matter
when it comes to this,
because in the ‐‐
I think you're taking away
the only time that men have.
It's just something I don't
resonate with, so I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
Yeah.
So, it can be a threat
towards men,
but people
keep buying these.
Mark, do you want to add a
Toilet Timer to your portfolio?
I've always
dreamed of that.
Yeah, what I like about
this is there's always
gonna be Father's Day.
There's always gonna be
a need for gags, right?
So I like it.
Obviously, you need money
for inventory,
so I understand
why you're here for that.
So I'll make you an offer.
Corcoran: Wow.
I'll offer you $200,000
that you asked for for 25%.
25%.
Okay.
I think we should
just do that.
Hey, Mark, let's make a deal
and let's do it, okay?
Corcoran: Good.
Let's do it, baby!
What a surprise ending.
This is awesome.
[ Grunts ]
Yes!
Appreciate it.
Thank you guys
all so much,
and thank you ‐‐
What you guys do for
American entrepreneurialism,
it's beautiful.
Thank you.
‐Thank you, Mark.
‐Bye. Congrats.
Adam: We didn't want to look
a gift horse in the mouth.
Mark was our only offer,
and there were some things
we could have countered with,
but at that point,
I didn't think it made sense.
We're okay with 25%.
We think that we can do great
business with this product.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is an innovative way
to shred the slopes.
♪♪
Wow.
What's up, Sharks?
Who's ready to ski
into a big old pile of money?
My name's Kevin Greco,
and I'm the chief
enthusiast officer for ODR.
I've been on skis
my entire life,
skied every inch
of every mountain I could
in my childhood home
of Alaska.
It was a snowy paradise
and an amazing experience,
except for the equipment.
Everything about traditional
equipment is inconvenient.
It's bulky, it's hard to learn,
and it's dangerous.
ODR skis are sleek
and hassle‐free,
easy to transport,
and a total thrill.
Check it out.
With ODR skis,
you get the rush of wind
blowing through your hair
without the risk
of out‐of‐control riding
or runaway speed,
and without bindings
or leverage points,
the common injuries that you see
in skiing and in snowboarding
are virtually eliminated.
What you're witnessing, Sharks,
is the inception of a sport
and a brand that is disrupting
the global ski industry.
So, we're seeking $350,000
for a 10% stake in ODR.
So, who's ready to join me?
'Cause it's all downhill
from here.
[ Laughs ]
Greiner: That's very cool.
Very cool.
Are there other ‐‐
anything else
out there like this?
So, we have started
to get some competition,
but what's unique about us
is that we're
a fully integrated system.
So despite looking
like ski boots,
they're actually flexible,
like a tennis shoe.
And then, lastly, this is really
our bread and butter.
We're the only one
in the industry
using a system called
liquid steel injection molding,
and what this gives the rider
is great edge control
on harder‐packed
groomed snow conditions.
Kevin, how long have you
been doing this?
I've been doing this
since 2017.
You started selling
in 2017 or...
In 2017, the company had been
around already for one year,
so they started in 2016.
And I'm sorry ‐‐
I think I missed something.
You said somebody else
was doing this initially?
Yes, so, I joined the company
in 2017 as a distributor,
and little did I know
that in a few short years,
I'd end up owning
the global brand.
So, obviously
there was a founder.
Tell us about
that journey.
Yes. I've always wanted
to be a disrupter.
I've always wanted to work
on technologies
that are
creating new opportunities.
So I saw a video
for this product,
and I was like,
"Oh, my goodness.
I have to figure out
how to be a part of this."
So I put in $100,000
to own the distribution rights
in North America
and then just built the company
and got so powerful here
and so big with the sales
that were being generated.
So, how did you get
all the equity into your name?
Yes. Sales, Kevin.
That's how I got it.
I got the equity
because I was a sales monster.
I was eating market share.
Say that again,
'cause I love to hear it.
[ Laughs ]
"I am a sales monster."
...a sales monster!
I built myself so big that I
overwhelmed their supply chain,
and they had to
make a choice.
The choice was
I take over the company
and they come with me on a ride
to the next winter sport
or I end up as a competitor.
Whoa!
Corcoran: Hardball!
Ba‐bam!
What percentage do you
own of the company now?
I own the entire company
worldwide now.
What did you pay
for the company?
So, my invested capital
was originally $100,000.
I ended up putting
in another $50,000,
and then I took on investment
to clear the buyout
of the entire company,
and that total transaction cost
another $200,000 on top of that.
Was this company originally
an international company?
Yes, ma'am.
Can you tell us
where that was?
Norway.
They were operating around
the world in over 20 countries.
And the problem with the model
is, I believed from day 1,
the key to the future
for winter sports
was a direct‐to‐consumer
model,
a product that was
easier to size, easier to fit,
and so I focused
on digital.
I'm a skier, okay?
Yes.
What makes this
any different
than the shorty that I have
already with a binding on it?
Sure.
And the challenge for shorties,
they're very unstable.
It's not easy to do
'cause you don't have
a lot of base on the snow.
So, we have riders that have
gone over 60 miles an hour
on the product
you see in front of you.
Just 'cause you can
doesn't mean you should.
You can achieve great speed.
One thing that's been very
near and dear to my heart is,
we haven't had
a serious reported injury
in the growth
that we've had,
which has been
really tremendous.
It comes down to
the fact that when you fall,
you fall naturally.
There's nothing
binding you up.
Like, I've always heard
it's the bindings.
Yes.
I decided not to become a skier
for that same reason.
However, I did become
a pretty good snowboarder.
I'm called Chocolate Powder
on the mountain.
Can you go in deep powder
with these?
So, they can work in fresh snow,
a few inches of fresh snow.
How can they be in deep snow?
There's no base.
That would be impossible,
Kevin.
Not deep powder.
Not, like, off trail.
And not that
that's that important,
'cause that's probably about,
what, 3% of riders?
I mean, the rest are on
regular slopes.
Correct.
What is the retail price on this
and your cost to make it?
So, it's $100,
our cost to make it,
and then we sell it
for an average ticket of $350.
And what is a typical ski boot?
Roughly $350 to $400, right?
Yes, ma'am,
and for an entire ski set,
it can be considerably
more than that.
What are your sales?
2016, $238,000 in sales.
I had yet to join
the company.
2017, I got involved halfway
through the season.
We did $660,000.
And you're crediting yourself
for that?
[ Chuckles ] Of course.
He's a sales monster.
2018, $977,000.
Okay,
what's the next year?
We're on track, conservatively,
to $1.5 million this season.
Are you gonna make any money
off the $1.5 million this year?
This year, we're going to be
approaching our profitability,
and that's because of
the direct‐to‐consumer
digital pivot.
You've never had
a profit to date?
We have, actually.
In 2018, we did $120,000.
The restriction has been
wholesale to distributors
around the world
with opportunity everywhere
versus me ‐‐ digital, digital,
digital, digital.
John:
Kev, I got one last question ‐‐
I just want to make sure
that I'm understanding
the story.
Sure.
A poor little guy in Norway
comes up with this great idea,
and then you come in,
and then you threaten
to take over the company
or become a competitor.
Yes.
If I become
a partner with you,
would you stab me in the back
the same way?
No. Not at all.
So, Daymond,
this is what happened.
I built just a really
tight‐knit family
of customers here in the US.
I was getting to meet them,
see them,
see how it was
affecting their life.
I was getting letters,
and they're saying, like,
"I got to see
my kid out there."
"I had a bad injury. Now I get
to be with him on the slopes."
And so it was
super powerful.
And what happened was,
when my supply chain
got just restricted,
they started to manipulate me.
They started say,
"If you want it now,
it's gonna be this price."
And I'd built this
really amazing following
and family here.
And so finally, we reached
just this breaking point,
and that's when it came up,
Daymond,
where I said,
"I cannot abandon the people
that I've put my blood, sweat,
and tears into
and my money into.
We're either gonna
move forward together
or, like,
I'm gonna do this on my own."
Alright, Kevin,
here's my decision.
I think this product
is impressive.
I know snowboarding.
I don't know anything
about skiing.
I think there's two
other people up here for sure
that are more skilled
in that area,
but I would be doing you
an injustice,
not bringing
more knowledge to this,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you, Daymond.
I love you.
Thank you, Lori.
You are amazing.
Any other product under the sun,
I'd be so in with you.
Problem is,
I'm not a skier.
And so, unfortunately,
for that reason, I'm out.
Okay.
Yeah, Kevin,
you're the perfect entrepreneur,
and I've never said that
the entire history
of being on "Shark Tank."
And I mean that seriously.
Thank you, Mark.
You love to sell
your product
because you know
how amazing it is,
but you understand
it's not about convincing.
It's about helping.
The problem is,
I've never skied in my life.
So while I am just
wowed by you,
for those reasons,
I'm out.
I'm pretty familiar
with the ski industry,
and frankly, $1.5 million
in sales for this year
is a really small amount
in the context
of the ski equipment industry,
which is in the billions.
It's so intriguing, but I can't
get there as an investor.
I'm sorry, Kev,
but I'm out.
Barbara's still in.
What do you want to do, Barb?
I'm sitting here
on the fence,
and I keep going on
one side of the fence
and getting, "Oh, I'm going
to the other side of the fence."
I do believe this is
a game changer,
and I really believe
in your vision for the sport.
I also like
your price structure.
You basically
get into this sport
for a third of what it would
cost you to get the skis,
the boots, the bindings,
the poles.
Yes.
To the other side,
here's what's bothering me.
When I sold my business,
at the 11th hour,
one of the most important
people in my business
held me up
for a million dollars.
She said, "You either
pay me a million
or I'm going
to your rival."
Now,
what do you think happened?
I gave her the million
immediately.
She would have
spoiled the deal.
The deal would have
been off.
The idea that you held a gun
to your employer's head ‐‐
That's not what happened,
Barbara.
Yes.
Cuban: Yeah, I don't see that
at all.
It isn't what happened,
Barbara.
Yes, I read that.
I read it that way.
I begged them for over a year,
and they wouldn't budge ‐‐
back and forth
and back and forth
and more constricted
and more constricted.
You are
a phenomenal salesman.
You'd be the top dog
in any industry.
Thank you.
But I have to say to you,
um...
Unh‐unh.
I wouldn't trust you.
I think I'd be worried
a little bit about my own back.
It's as simple as that,
so I'm out.
Good luck, Kevin.
Thank you so much.
Appreciate it.
Good luck, Kevin.
Alright.
Barbara's, I'm sure,
been in many situations
like the one she described,
and those situations
can really scar you.
All of the Sharks, I believe,
are gonna regret
not making a deal today,
as they watch this company
grow into the future
and do amazing things.
It was his relationships
with the customers,
not the people in Norway.
No, but I'm gonna tell you,
that's not the tone.
The tone here was "I took over
the company. I did it."
Yes. That's how I felt.
And I think there was
some bravado.
That's how I felt
during the opening of it.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a product
that solves
a danger for children
that many are unaware of.
♪♪
Hi. I'm Dahlia Rizk
from Windham, New Hampshire,
and I'm here seeking $100,000
in exchange
for 10% of my company,
Buckle Me Baby Coats.
Before we get started,
I wanted to ask you guys ‐‐
how many of you
have been personally victimized
by a toddler?
Yeah.
Kids are exhausting,
and getting them
into the car seat safely
is a battle that gets even worse
in the wintertime.
You see, most parents still
don't know that both the NHTSA
and the American Academy
of Pediatrics
recommend taking puffy coats
off in the car seat.
The puffiness of the coat
compresses
underneath the harness,
and experts have found
that the teeniest amount
of extra forward movement
creates critical brain, neck,
and spine injuries,
or worse, they can be thrown
from the car seat.
Like all parents,
I totally wanted my daughter
to be strapped in safely.
But my reality was,
she was freaking out.
I thought to myself,
"What are my options?"
I could take her
out of her coat,
but it is freezing outside.
I could leave the coat on,
but it's dangerous.
I felt like I had to choose
between safety,
warmth, and convenience,
but I wanted all three.
I thought to myself, "Shouldn't
there be an easier, safer way?"
So I invented one.
Buckle Me Baby Coats'
patented design
opens along the shoulder seams
and the side,
allowing parents
to put the coats on at home,
put their child in the car seat
the way they normally do,
pulling the one hand through,
then pulling through
the other hand.
And the difference in the coat
is in this front panel.
When you pull it
out of the way,
it allows the harness
to sit directly on
the chest and shoulders...
Clever.
...with absolutely
no puffy fabric in the way.
The back of the coat is thinner
than the front, as well.
This allows the harness
to be pulled
to the same exact tightness
as no coat at all.
I'm sure you've had your share
of battles with your kids.
Unsafe coats in the car seat
should never be one of them.
So, Sharks, who will join me
in making kids' winter coats
exactly what they should be ‐‐
easy and convenient for parents
and safe and warm for kids?
Dahlia, how many people know
this is a problem?
So, every year,
the news will talk about it
almost incessantly
starting in September.
They recommend that parents
take coats off.
A recent automobile study
found
that about 65% of parents
continue to leave coats on,
whether it's because
they don't know
or because
it's just too inconvenient.
They really don't
talk about that.
'Cause until you walked into
the Shark Tank,
I've never heard
of this problem.
I never have, either.
John:
When was that "Aha" moment
that you realized
that this was needed right now?
So, I was
one of those parents
who just really wanted to do
everything right by my daughter,
and I was paranoid
about her car seat,
and car seats are hard
to put in correctly,
and it's easier now than it was
when my daughter was little.
She's now 21.
She was about 5
when I thought of this.
So you've been working
on this 16 years?
No. I had to
put the brakes on it.
Why did it take 16 years?
So, when I first thought
of the coats,
I called around
to every coat manufacturer
that you could think of,
and none of them thought
that coats and car seats had
anything to do with one another.
They were simply
just not interested in the idea.
And Facebook wasn't a thing,
so I had no way
to reach parents directly.
Exactly, yeah.
And I was at the point where
I was starting my master's,
and I'm like, "I can either
do this or do that,"
and the master's seemed like
more of a sure thing.
And then as my kids grew older
and my marriage ended,
I started thinking,
"What are the things
I'm passionate about
that I've always wanted to do?"
And around that same time,
I was walking through
the parking lot,
and I saw this mother walking,
and she had
her daughter in this blanket.
The blanket was dragging
through the slush,
and she looked miserable
and defeated ‐‐
the way I felt
when I first thought of it,
and I'm like, "I can't believe
that's still not a thing.
I'm going to make a prototype."
I threw it on Facebook.
It exploded.
And then I just scrambled
to learn the rest,
and it's been a really crazy
journey, but here I am.
Welcome to
entrepreneur life.
I know.
It's been really fun.
So, what does a coat
typically cost a parent,
and what does it cost you
to make?
They cost me between
$14 to $15 landed,
and I sell them from
$59.99 to $129.
Where are you selling them,
and how much have you sold?
I have sold about $700,000
worth of coats
in the past three years.
Whoa!
Wow!
$700,000?
Cuban: Over what period
of time?
Over the past three years,
and $500,000 was just
in this past year alone.
I've done all of this from
the ground up all by myself.
I've had no investors.
I've had no help.
I've been trying to put as
much money into inventory
instead of
into hiring people.
Where do you sell them?
75%, I sell online
through my website and Amazon,
and then the other 25%,
I sell to a big box store.
What do you envision
your sales are going to
be this current year?
My sales this year
are a little bit conservative.
My growth has been about
250% to 350%,
but around the time when
I was about to place
the order for this year
was when COVID started
to become more recognizable,
and I thought to myself ‐‐
if I order what I had planned
to order, which was about
$1.3 million in inventory...
Wow.
...and people are stuck at home
and nobody's traveling...
I'm by myself ‐‐
I don't have any backers,
I don't have investors ‐‐
and this will put me under.
So what did you do?
You put the brakes on
because of COVID‐19?
I didn't put the brakes on.
I just purchased
more conservatively.
And long‐term, what do you
envision for your business?
If I find a coat company
that is as passionate
about car seat coats
and keeping the safety aspect ‐‐
it's not just a gimmick ‐‐
Then you can license it
to them.
...I'm open to
selling the company
and letting it move on
and really reach more parents.
That's what I'd like to do.
And do you have
a patent?
I have a utility patent,
but not only is it
a utility patent,
but it's a foundational patent,
meaning that it is
the first patent for a coat
designed for the car seat,
and I also have trademarks.
Greiner: That's great.
As an investor, if I ask you
"How do I get my $100,000 back,"
do I have to wait
till you sell the company?
Well, there are several ways
that I could do it, right?
So I'd really like to start
looking into
distribution overseas.
If you're interested in helping
with distribution overseas,
we could do some sort of
percentage on those sales.
Oh!
Did I hear "royalty"?
Maybe. [ Laughs ]
Okay.
So, how much are you spending
on advertising per month?
I spend about $8,000 to $10,000
on advertising,
and it costs me,
depending on the platform,
between $15 to $18
per customer.
So it's costing you $30
worst case.
Yeah.
So your worst case
is 50% margins,
and your best case
is 100% margins.
Yep.
So you're putting
half a million dollars
in the bottom line.
Yes.
Yeah,
you're investing in assets.
Yes. Yes.
Oh, thank you. Thank you.
You remind me so much of myself
and the road that I went.
Oh, that's quite
the compliment.
I knew nothing about how to
create or market my product.
I had no business background,
but I just figured it out.
I often have thought back
and ask myself ‐‐
if I had somebody
buy out my company
or if I had somebody
give me a loan,
what would I have done?
And I don't think
I'd be where I am today,
because I think the fact
that I had to play every role
and learn every facet of running
and driving a business
made me smarter and better
and able to get to
where I am today.
But I don't think
that you need a partner.
I think you're doing great
on your own.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
I appreciate your time.
Lori's right. You don't need
somebody to come in here.
Can I tell you why I do?
Sure.
Yes, we'd like to hear.
Okay. I'm here
for a strategic partner, right?
And you guys
can open doors faster.
To your point,
there's still a lot of families
that don't know,
and among those that do know ‐‐
That's not retail
you're talking about.
But that's marketing.
That's marketing.
That's marketing,
and I'm working ‐‐
Cuban: My point is, Dahlia,
you can hire somebody for that
that's really good.
Look, all of us
can help promote,
but honestly, this isn't
the right area for me.
So for those reasons, I'm out,
but congratulations.
Thank you, Mark.
I mean, what you've
accomplished is stellar.
Thank you very much.
Dahlia, I'm gonna make you
an offer of $100,000,
but I want 20%.
And I'm gonna tell you
why you need me.
You're gonna use me
to build your business
so that you reach your goal
of selling your business,
which you clearly stated here,
and I know how to do that.
I think you should listen
to all the offers.
♪♪
Narrator:
Two Sharks are out.
Dahlia has one offer
on the table from Barbara
for her car seat‐safe coat
company, Buckle Me Baby Coats.
Dahlia, I'm gonna make you
an offer of $100,000,
but I want 20%.
I think you should listen
to all the offers.
Dahlia, I've got
a fantastic offer for you.
I love your business,
but I'm not greedy.
I don't need that much equity,
so here's what I'm gonna do.
Your margins are fantastic.
You can afford a royalty.
So I'm gonna ask
for $2 a unit
until I recoup $300,000.
And I want 2.5% equity
just because I think one day,
you will sell the company,
and I'd like to participate
in the upside
and be kind of
a partner with you.
But it's
an alternate to Barbara.
She's very greedy.
You know, 20%.
I'm not the least bit ‐‐
[ Laughs ]
I find that disgusting.
But never mind.
You know,
the best way to get a buy
is to get a license
in between,
and I know the three people
in the space
that kind of handle
all the kids' coats.
I think that the best thing
would be to do a fusion.
I'll give you $100,000 for 20%
of the traditional business,
and it would be
30% of all licenses I bring in.
So it doesn't disrupt
your core business.
Then all the other brands
that are making the kids' coats
for Peppa Pig,
to license it out to them,
so then you get to cover
both bases.
You get to push out a lot of
stuff on somebody else's dollar
and then market
your core business
and make the money
at the same time.
Dahlia, I share one thing
in common with you,
and it's not
a bad place to start.
I have a common goal
with you.
I invested in
an apparel company, the Comfy,
and I already, in three years,
have built their business
to $250 million in sales.
I could do that
for your business,
and I'm
your perfect partner,
But I'll again
restate my offer.
I want to give you $100,000
for a straight 20%.
Why give up so much?
Would you be willing
to do 15%?
No.
No?
Would you?
♪♪
Keep the 30% as it is
but do 15%?
It's the same thing I'm saying
that Barbara's saying.
The whole purpose
of the licenses
is to get it out there
so somebody says,
"Well, we have to acquire it."
Yes.
So, you're coming down
to 15%, Daymond?
She's asking me. I don't know
if I'm coming down to it yet.
You have to
make a decision.
I have to make a decision.
You really want to give up
20% of your company?
♪♪
Daymond,
I'll take your offer.
Cuban: Whoo!
There you go.
Congrats.
Wow!
Alright, that's it.
You're done, guys.
The people that
I'm talking about working with,
I've been working with them
for 25 years, right?
Yeah.
So this is
where I started.
You're gonna make millions
of dollars on this, literally.
You're gonna make
millions of dollars less 20%.
Sorry.
[ Laughs ]
Less 15%.
Oh, you're 15%?
No, I'm 20%.
Oh, I thought you agreed.
Oh!
Whoa!
I thought you agreed.
I never said
that I would budge on that.
That is true.
You did not say that.
♪♪
Dahlia, what is the deal?
20% on the $100,000,
and it's 30%
on the licensing.
Correct.
Okay.
Mazel tov!
Alright.
Now we have a deal!
Thank you. Thank you.
High fives.
Thank you so much.
Nicely done, really.
Thank you. Thank you.
Cuban: Well done.
I am so excited.
It went better than I thought
it could possibly go,
and I got the Shark
I was hoping for,
and I am super excited
to work with Daymond
to get so many coats into
the hands of so many families.
♪♪